panzer die neat rollen schiffe die nicht
fahren und jets und hubschrauber die
nicht fliegen in einem wort bundeswehr
aber jetzt soll aus der pannen truppe ja
die modernste nicht atomare streitmacht
europas werden mit sagenhaften 100
milliarden euro steuergeldern finanziert
die woanders nicht fehlen sollen weil es
ja ein sondervermögen ist man muss nur
den richtigen namen finden jedenfalls
wissen will jetzt wofür genau das geld
ausgegeben werden soll bild liegt
exklusiv die anschaffungs liste vor aber
der reihe nach
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
aber machen wir uns nichts vor bessere
ausrüstung und dann ist einsatzgerät
mehr personal das kostet viel geld der
bundeshaushalt
2022 wird dieses sondervermögen einmalig
mit 100 milliarden euro ausstatten
angekündigt am 28
februar durch bundeskanzler olaf scholz
vier tage nachdem putin seinen
angriffskrieg auf die ukraine startete
100 milliarden euro für die bundeswehr
seit anfang der woche weiß der
finanzminister woher all dieses geld
nehmen es ist ein
großer erfolg dass dir die vom
bundeskanzler
bezeichnete zeitenwende nun auch mit
konkreten taten
unterlegen können wir ertüchtigen und
verstärken jetzt die bundeswehr um die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung zu
gewährleisten eine lange zeit der
vernachlässigung der streitkräfte wird
damit beendet 100 milliarden euro
zusätzliche investitionen für die
bundeswehr werden erlauben dass die
streitkräfte ihrem auftrag dann auch
gerecht werden können 100 milliarden
euro für die bundeswehr doch was will
die regierung davon eigentlich genau
kaufen bild weiß dass uns liegt exklusiv
die geheime 100 milliarden euro
einkaufsliste der regierung vor so jetzt
sind wir gespannt und gehen diese liste
mal durch und zwar mit bild chefreporter
peter tiede wer hier bei mir im studio
espeter fangen wir mal an mit dem für
die soldaten wahrscheinlich am
wichtigsten da wo sie sozusagen der
schuh am meisten drückt im wahrsten
sinne 2 milliarden euro für ausrüstung
sollen ausgegeben werden also neue kampf
schuhe für die truppe gehörschutz und
moderne nachtsichtgeräte neue schuhe bei
der bundeswehr viel es tatsächlich an
allem also von der luft bis zum boden
wirklich erst dann wirklich bei
elementaren sachen an die brauchen neue
kampf schuhe sind müssen neue arten auf
die neue einsätze und es fängt wirklich
ganz banal bei der sohle an und geht bis
über den helm bis ins weltall rein
knobelbecher sagte man früher ja ich
fast 40 fast 41 milliarden euro sollen
für neue kampfjets ausgegeben werden und
zwar einen neuen euro fighter den
hochmodernen
f-35 tarnkappen jet der kommt aus der us
produktion von lockheed wenn ich richtig
informiert bin und neue
transporthubschrauber ja also neue
transporthubschrauber und andere technik
das klingt so als wenn er etwas
ausgewechselt wurde aber da haben wir
denn zumindest mal technik die auch
funktioniert wie in leiden ja daran dass
unsere tornados kaum noch einsätze
fliegen können es gab immer die
peinlichkeit dass wir bei bestimmten
wetterlagen überhaupt nicht fliegen
konnten selbst die aufklärung singer
nicht weil displays spiegelten bei alles
mögliche nicht funktioniert hat und aus
schrott wird jetzt tatsächlich gold das
rollt läuft und schwimmt und auch fliegt
unterhalt bei den flugzeugen bei den
hubschrauber was besonders dramatisch da
haben wir einfach extrem nachholebedarf
interessant ja dass diese f-35 aus den
usa kommen das war ja lange nicht
geplant weil es auch ein rückschlag für
das gemeinsame europäische projekt
eurofighter ist aber offenbar können die
europäer mit den amerikanern nicht mit
ja und wie hans gesehen bei den
eurocopter bei bestimmten hubschrauber
dass es da immer zu problemen kam und
wenn es schon material gibt das fliegt
und das zuverlässig flieht und auch im
rhythmus modernes warum dann nicht alles
kann man jetzt auch nicht aus dem
eigenen baukasten schaffen mehr als 16
milliarden euro sollen für neue hansa
ausgegeben werden vor allem für
schützenpanzer ein paar werden uns
fehlen die wir liefern aber das dauert
ja noch ja und auch danach wurde bedarf
bisher war es so dass wenn ich sage mal
ganz salopp wenn der russe gekommen wäre
mit den panzern hätten uns die polen
retten müssen weil die polen tatsächlich
konventionell besser waren und da
stellen wir uns jetzt besser auf und wir
brauchen schlicht und ergreifend für
bestimmte typen der panzer brauchen wir
einfach nachfolger oder aber panzer die
schon mal eine ausschreibung waren die
man noch wo man optionen ziehen kann wie
beim puma zum beispiel die werden jetzt
gezwungen die kita wird er als
möglichkeit von der möglichkeit gebrauch
gemacht sachen die in der produktion
sind dann auch zu kaufen und nach zu
bestellen und es wären tatsächlich auch
nachfolgemodelle neu entwickelt also
wirklich auch auf diesem feld auf diesem
wichtigen konventionellen kriegsfeld
gibt es nachholbedarf bei der bundeswehr
und der witz gestellten großer brocken
brocken ein fünftel 20 milliarden euro
werden an die marine gehen für neue
korvetten und moderne flugabwehr körper
ja dringend notwendig also wären
deutsche häfen guckt und gesehen hat wie
es der deutschen marine gibt geht der
weiß dass er nicht viel geht um gute
vier noch auf der liste meine frau kommt
aus eckernförde die halbe familie kommt
aus kommt aus dem bereich und die waren
immer schon wenn die über über die bucht
gucken und auf den us-stützpunkt gucken
zum beispiel wenn jetzt noch zwei
fahrtüchtige u boote liegen und die
können aber nicht auslaufen weil ein
smoothie fehlt zumindest alles was über
wasser ist wird jetzt aufgerüstet auch
da auf neue herausforderungen nämlich
auch mehr auf die luftabwehr also wenn
der fan von von oben kommt dann muss die
marine nachgerüstet werden und das zielt
natürlich ganz eindeutig auf die
bedrohung die wir auch in der baltischen
see haben die fernost sie haben sagt mal
ganz salopp werden der putin fliegen
lässt also in 15 jahren können wir denn
da auch hin lang
stichwort zukunft 21 milliarden euro
sollen in die digitalisierung gehen also
noch mal mehr als in dem marine für
moderne kommunikation der truppen für
satelliten und navigation und zwei
stunden stöhr
stört resistenter zu werden und auch
dass nicht jeder mithören kann was die
deutsche bundeswehr sich dazu funkt da
muss ganz viel geld getan wenn man muss
sagen wir haben zum beispiel alles was
im weltraum angeht die aufklärung da
sind wir wirklich gut wir sind
traditionell gut in der funk auf
aufklärung das ist wirklich bis heute so
und in der sicherung der modestandort er
jetzt berühmt geworden
hiervon sind ja darin reisen manchmal
ministerin hin wenn sie hat ja noch nach
sylt von aber spaß beiseite wir haben
über bremen über unsere weltraum
techniker die da in bremen sind haben
wir zum beispiel denkt die modernste mit
die modernste radar aufklärung das heißt
wir können durch die wolken durch gucken
und zwar relativ fast zentimetergenau
auch feinde bestimmen und sehen wo zum
beispiel heute schon russische offiziere
sind aber die kommunikation in der
truppe selber muss satellitengestützt
werden die muss weiterreichen und die
muss man wirklich auf den neuesten stand
gebracht werden auch nah kommt die
zukunft jetzt tatsächlich irgendwann mal
auch in der bundes werden irgendwann
einmal das die entscheidende frage die
zukunft wann wird das alles umgesetzt
werden wenn wir jetzt schon sehen wie
lange es dauert um die alten panzer in
stand zu setzen um sie an die ukraine zu
liefern wie lange wird das dauern bis
all diese pläne umgesetzt also da sind
sachen dabei die werden sehr schnell
gehen wir müssen einmal sagen die liste
die bild jetzt hier vorliegt die wir
gezeigt haben die hat die kollegin
angelika hellemann für uns bild besorgt
mich dass ich mich immer mit fremden
federn schmücken also diese liste da
sind sachen drauf die kommen teilweise
schnell schuhe kann schnell gehen helme
bestimmte funkausrüstung die fürs feld
vorgesehen ist die ganz schnell kommen
aber neue waffentypen nachfolger für
panzer die müssen noch entwickelt werden
da steckt richtig entwicklungsarbeit in
der 15 jahre teilweise 20 jahre wird es
dauern aber so etwas ist ein prozess das
ist ein bisschen wie die deutsche
wiedervereinigung sie haben wir die
bundeswehr ist momentan in einem zustand
wie die ddr volkswirtschaft das dauert
eine weile bis du das wieder
hochgepäppelt hast das ist jetzt quasi
das große aufbauprojekt für die
bundeswehr eine blühende landschaften
für die rüstungsindustrie auch da aber
warum sollen die nicht daran verdient
andere haben am aufbau ost auch verdient
warum nicht die nicht die
rüstungsindustrie auch da in deutschland